[Music]
in 3 2
action so good good good
[Music]
good bad anyone but him I didn't approve
him you know that you are literally the
last person on Earth I want to see it
slapped the out of you I really
could and I'm open to that in a safer
environment you been a ghost no phone
call no
text it's not like I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame so how have you
been God I hate that thumbs up stun gu
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this man on fire you're a stunk guy
we need to keep it super profes profes
is my middle name you said your middle
name was
danger how do we do
boss really yeah holster there it's
Holsted it's done forget you you never
saw
it Tom
Ryder the biggest action star on the
planet is missing you need to bring him
back on Jody's movie is dead why me
you're a stump man nobody's going to
notice you that's your job no offense
I'm I mean some taking you find Ryder
save Jody's film you get the love of
your life back I'm not the hero I'm just
a double not today you're
not Tom we need you back on set
[Music]
pal oh
dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail he
was super
dead he has got himself involved with
some shady
people I had no choice I had to do some
Jason board
they were trying to kill
me and not in a fun way you
making you yeah made it it's too
dangerous got to be stairs go go
what happened to your face you look
terrible you look
amazing you fall down you get right back
up how far would you go for the one that
you
love how BL you drink when this is over
engage your
core yeah
boy what you doing later want to go to a
beach somewhere drink a spicy Margarita
make some bad decisions yes
oh to the heart and you're
[Applause]
to oh hey Dan happy
anniversary Dan my husband he's an
amazing dad you almost said to go a size
4S huh how you so big look at the big
musos I just wish our lives
were big
really at least let me put my kid
down wa up on a six sorry about the mess
hold
on oh hey b hey
Dan don't hang up I need no identities
I'm burned me my wife and three kids
have you told them yet I'll tell them
when I'm on the road meet me in Vegas in
3 days this is crazy oh to God we're
going to
Vegas woo oh so pumped nothing brings
the family together like a road
trip stop collaborate and listen I is
back with a brand
new 5 hours on a plane or 33 hours in a
car can someone unlock the car
please call in
everybody I want him
F what was that little pothole Maxi's
been up the whole time by the way much
as biger that Bo I'm killing
you when I play a do Melody anything
less than a b is wish
that before I met your mom I was a
covert assassin I escaped that life and
now they found
us what
the being your husband and their father
that's the real
me you're like James Bond in a minivan I
love that
minivan I need to be that guy one last
time time for
us look at you blind of family man I'm
not playing this is my
life heang I'm kind of into spontaneous
dance wait wait
[Music]
go new
record
you're a blessing Mr Clay this place was
crab grass and weeds and you brought it
back to
life Mrs Parker and I were friends she
was like family she was the only person
who ever took care of
me I just got a message saying that
there's a problem with my computer yes
ma'am we got
this yesterday she shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm counter to three 1 2
3 there I did it for
you no
you I'm going to burn this place to the
ground will you stop his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is he's a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's not
good beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have laws for
these things until they fail then you
have
me my fingers he cut them off what the
bro don't
move
bow
down this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scan the money's going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem got damn
right I'm a
problem no way he's coming to straight
through the back entrance I figured i'
give the firefighters a break somebody
detain this guy
we have to kill him before he kills his
way to the
top
honey it's flammable as who
knew going to
get
[Music]
foreign
spee
[Music]
takee
you
go forus
onee
hey come on get your stuff let's
[Music]
go let's try that
again a week ago I spent my life racing
Against Time I'm going to help you out
today okay trying to save people who are
running out of it until one
moment changed
everything come on Welcome Back to the
land that we're
living but I don't understand what's
happening I've been having
Vision I knew he was going to
die I think I'm seeing the
future New York City is a whole new
level of crazy these days
what do you want from
me New York City is a whole new level of
crazy these days this is an emergency
get off the train that man's trying to
kill you what who are you what is going
on I can see the
future oh what the hell she didn't see
that coming that's not how it
works I've seen that before so who is he
Ezekiel Sims he was in the Amazon with
my mom when she was researching spiders
right before she
died wait I recognize you you live in my
building you're the paramedic yeah you
almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how
we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all
day do you you have no idea what those
girls have come why don't
I think he can see into the
future he's trying to change what
happens you get
down why AR you scared of me why do you
for me your future was almost so
different if you want to live you have
to trust
me get
ready
now
you're showing off maybe a
little when I
sleep I see strange
[Music]
things
memories not
Memories
new
things I see
everything that is
not
[Music]
everything
who what a wonderful
day hi baby boy talking to the fishies
you and me son we're different we're
special we're connected to the land and
the sea I can't wait to introduce you to
all the majestic creatures on our planet
show you how awesome this world can
be yeah you and
me I'm going to kill
[Music]
Aquaman even if I have to make a deal
with the devil to do
it free me from my prison and all my
power will be yours the key to this
prison is the Royal bloodline
itself he needs us We're The End Of The
Bloodline no we're
not
yeah Manta took
junior he must be
stopped I'm coming for
you destroy everything he holds
dear You Want Blood come get
[Applause]
it I certainly hope you dance as well as
you
dress there's only one way to find
[Music]
out you and I when Not So Different
agent
Ary it'll help hold
[Music]
on the book is phenomenal sweetie
but what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother ell it's called a
copout whoa hey there's a cat in there
oh my God you're Ellie freaking Conway
author of ARG series Ellie
Conway I am such a fan oh yeah what does
it you do Espionage would you sign my
book here we
go I love this
book come on
[Music]
he who are these people real life spies
why would they care about me because
you're a goddamn fortune teller
Ellie when you wrote in your new book
actually happened and you Kicked the
Hornets Nest you didn't even know
existed I'm in some really big trouble
Mom oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next chapter I
love it too
bab God I hate that
[Music]
cat it's time for you to meet the real
agent
Argy oh my God oh my God God oh my
[Music]
[Applause]
God I'm telling you it's going to be
another hot one out there in fact there
are heat alerts in effect for New Jersey
feeling like
[Music]
100° leaving me here on my
own what is
that
for the first time in New York history
people froze to death in the middle of
July what is it the death
chill the power killed by fear
itself your veins turn to rivers of ice
your bones crack and the last thing you
see is your own tear Ducks freezing
up like literally scared to death so
[Music]
cool
I'm not an enforcer I'm more like a um a
fixer
exactly I have to convince a certain
person that the bodyy in that trunk out
there is indeed Rolo something happened
to his
face what the it's Miss along with the
rest of his head
betrayal is a funny thing it's very
naturous to catch you
unaware you ever heard a ring
doorbell we're under
attack stance
gone and you should be too I've always
heard one rule s be good to the people
who were good to you be good to yourself
Charlie and get as far away from here as
you
can turned on your own you want to get
out of buuy char that's what everyone
keeps telling
me that 50 Grand could really change
things for me I'm going with it without
[Music]
you ask Charlie I got more men than you
got bullets bullets are easy to
get what do you want you not breathing
and how you going to do that I'm doing
it
we for long time you know you really
ought to start thinking about an Exit
Plan what are you waiting
for pull the trigger
[Music]
Charlie over your
head I don't like
loose he was my second best guy I'm
looking forward to meeting number
one this is not my
[Music]
world I've never been to this Lake
before never walked at
Shores but I will find my way back and I
will find my way back to my
Molly light
5 years ago I was left in this dark
place taken from my
[Music]
wife the people here have no hope you
still looking for that wife of yours
you're clinging the scraps of rumors and
then he
arrived where's my wife I shifted her
for every choice you make there are
countless other realities we make a
different Choice you're talking about
parallel Earths imagine having the power
to move people from One reality to the
next to shift
down what do you want with me I can make
you a king imagine everything you have
ever
wanted work for me and get back with the
woman that you love okay we go on a date
and maybe baby kiss hopefully he's might
to shift you back to your wife it's a
trick if I choose you that's the last
Choice I'm ever going to
make I will never leave you
alone I've seen a bunch of people like
us out there looking for a little
hope there is nothing that I won't do to
you
it sh it sh it sh you can't just shoot
the
devil there is so much evil and
inhumanity in this world but there is
also Beauty and hope and I will find my
way back to
[Music]
her hi I'm Elizabeth tabish and I'm so
excited for you guys to see my latest
project from Angel Studios I play Molly
Garner in the shift which comes out this
December Angel Studios theatrical
releases have always sold out the first
weekend so be sure to get your tickets
now you can get them at angel.com slthe
shift this world is beyond
cruelty you've been fighting the hinin
for decades my family's been fighting
them for
centuries and they were
massacred alongside my father your
father didn't believe in
Revenge we believe in fman only me fight
beside
you
reload he said I got that
thanks I won't be fighting for him I'm
fighting for my
[Music]
people you young
pop do you believe in po there are
signs the prophet where is that a bad
thing use
it because all my Visions lead to horror
because you lose control because I gain
it Johnny do you believe in
me Paul the trades is still
alive deal with this
Prophet show me who you
are
your
father was a weak
man look who's back from the
dead now do it must be
done we gave them something to hope for
that's not
hope got
it I will love you as long as I
breathe
this prophecy is how they enslave
us it's not a prophecy it's a story I
don't care what you believe I
believe I amul Diva
traes Duke of
[Music]
baracus he who can destroy a thing has
the real control of
[Music]
[Applause]
it my son never show
Mercy they are pray
we are
predators boys your mother is
dead she died because you sent her away
she was weak sick in her mind you know
my business
yes power is about
strength if you show
weakness you will give our enemy an
opening shoot
shoot he's weak like his mother leave
him what happened that
day I stared death in the face and for
the first time I saw my true
self tell me about this Hunter
they say he uses a connection with
animals to track his
prey once you're on his
list there's only one way off there's
six of us there only one of you there's
six of you
now why do you hunt my father puts evil
into the
world I take it
out
think you have some kind of Honor you
were exactly like our father just
another man hunting for a
trophy we're
murderers isn't that what he taught
us you don't get to do that to me
anymore Mr
tlan Mr
techlin where's Mr tlin oh you're
standing in
him
you're goddamn lunatic oh you just
figure that out
now there is an animal in each one of us
don't you want to know why they call me
the
rhino
[Music]
shots fired shots fired all units please
respond
[Music]
so
this
you
ever since I was a child people said my
family was
cursed mom tried to protect us with
God pop tried to protect us with
wrestling he said if we were the
toughest the strongest nothing you ever
Hur
us I believed him we all
did morning pants tomorrow please
David Carri I want you to join your
brothers in the ring yes sir I love that
now we all know Carrie's my favorite
then Kev then David then Mike but the
rankings can always change what do you
want in life Kevin ER more ribs I want
to be with my family you know be with my
brothers
what do you like to do with your
brothers har and
David together we can do
anything we're here to restore Justice
to the Wrestling Federation that our
father built with his own two hands the
hands that were passed down to us the
hands that will deliver the iron clock
to
you so what do you think like world a
lot I love your family
K you going to be an uncle yes sir oh
man that makes me so happy I talk to you
about something tomorrow dad's too tough
from us you got to say something babbe
that's what your brothers are for you
feel that you feel that that's
pressure you're pushing too hard I'm
fine K seriously I'm just
sick go I'm scared man it all my out of
control was a terrible accident
I should have stopped him I need to
think about my family your job is to
wrestle live up to that deal while we
are
through I thought going to look out for
him I just love being out there with you
guys it's the only thing that matters to
me the will forever be the greatest
family in the history of
[Applause]
wrest
go
[Music]
for foreign
speech
fore
speee
[Music]
foree fore
speech for
[Music]
spee